do you think we need to understand the
brain
in order to build it yes if you want to
build the brain
we definitely need to understand how it
works so
blue brain or henry markham's project
is trying to build a brain without
understanding it like just trying to
uh put details of the brain
from neuroscience experiments into a
giant simulation
uh by putting more and more neurons more
and more details uh but that
is not going to work uh because
when it doesn't perform as uh what you
expect
it to do then what do you do you do you
just keep adding more details
how do you debug it so it's a so unless
you
understand unless you have a theory
about how the system is supposed to work
how the pieces are supposed to fit
together what they're going to
contribute
you can't you can't build it at the
functional level understand
so can you actually linger on and
describe the blue brain project
it's kind of a fascinating uh
principle an idea to try to simulate the
brain
it's we're talking about the human brain
right right human brains
and rad brains or cat brains
have lots in common that the cortex the
neocortex
structure is very similar so initially
they were trying to
just simulate a cat brain and uh
to understand the nature of evil i
didn't understand the nature of
evil uh or uh as it happens in most of
these simulations
uh you you easily get one thing out
which is
oscillations you know yeah if you if you
simulate a large number of neurons
they oscillate and you can adjust the
parameters and
say that oscillations match the rhythm
that we see in the brain
etc but uh i see so like uh so the idea
is uh
is the simulation at the level of
individual neurons
yeah so the blue brain project the
original
idea as proposed was you
you put very detailed bio physical
neurons
bios physical models of neurons and
you interconnect them according to the
statistics of connections that we have
found from real neuroscience experiments
and then turn it on and uh see what
happens
uh and and these neural models are you
know incredibly complicated
in themselves right because these
neurons are
uh modeled using uh this idea called
hodgkin huxley models which are
about how signals propagate in a cable
and there are active dendrites all those
phenomena
which those phenomena themselves we
don't understand
that well and then we put in
connectivity which is
part guess work but you know observed
and
of course if you do not have any theory
about how it is supposed to work
uh we you know we just have to
take whatever comes out of it as okay
this is something interesting but in
your sense like these models of the way
signal travels
along or like with the axons and all the
basic models
that's they're too crude oh well
actually
they are pretty detailed and pretty
sophisticated
and they do replicate the
neural dynamics if you take a single
neuron
and you you try to
turn on the different channels the
calcium channels and
the different receptors uh and see what
the effect of
uh turning on or off those channels are
in the neurons spike output people have
built pretty sophisticated models of
that and
and they are i i would say um
you know in the regime of correct well
see the correctness
that's interesting because you've
mentioned in several levels uh
the correctness is measured by looking
at some kind of aggregate statistics
it would be more of the the spiking
dynamics of the
spike in dynamics yeah and and
yeah these models because they are they
are going to the level of mechanism
right so they are
basically looking at uh okay what what
is the effect of
turning on an ion channel uh and um
and you can you can model that using
electric circuits in
and then so they are model so it is not
just
a uh function fitting it is people are
looking at the mechanism underlying it
and uh putting that in terms of electric
circuit uh
theory signal propagation theory and and
modeling that and
so those models are sophisticated but
getting a
single neurons model 99
right does not still tell you how to
you know it would be the analog of
getting a transistor
model right and now trying to build a
microprocessor
um and if you if you just uh observe you
know if you did not understand how a
microprocessor works
uh but you say oh i have i now can model
one transistor well
and now i will just try to interconnect
the transistors
according to whatever i could you know
guess from the experiments
and try to simulate it um then
it is very unlikely that you will
produce a functioning microprocessor
um you want to you know when you want to
uh produce a functioning microprocessor
you want to understand
boolean logic how does how do the the
gates work
all those things and then you know
understand how do those gates get
implemented using transistors
yeah there's actually i remember this
reminds me this is a paper
maybe you're familiar with it i remember
going through in a reading group
that approaches a microprocessor from a
perspective of a neuroscientist
i think it it basically it uses all the
tools that we have of neuroscience to
try to understand like as if we just
aliens showed up to study computers uh
yeah and and to see if if those tools
could be used to get
any kind of sense of how the
microprocessor works
i think the final the takeaway from
the at least this initial uh exploration
is that
we're screwed there's no way that the
tools in neuroscience would be able to
get us
to anything like not even bullying logic
i mean it's
just a any aspect
of the architecture of the uh
function of the processes involved
the the clocks the the timing all that
you can't figure that out from the tools
of neuroscience
yeah so i'm very familiar with this this
particular paper uh i think it was uh
called can a neuroscientist understand a
microprocessor yeah something like that
following the methodology
in that paper even an electrical
engineer would not understand
microprocessors so i could
so i could so i i don't think it is
that bad in the sense of saying um
neuroscientists do
find valuable things uh by observing the
brain
they they do find good insights um
but those insight cannot be put together
just as a simulation you have to you
have to investigate
what are the computational underpinnings
pinnings of
those findings how do all of them
fit together from an information
processing
perspective you have to you have to
somebody has to
painstakingly put those things together
and build hypothesis um
so i don't want to this all of
neuroscience is saying oh they are not
finding anything no that
you know that that paper almost went to
that level of uh
neuroscientists will never understand no
that that's not true i think they do
find lots of useful things
but it has to be put together in a
computational framework
yeah i mean but you know just the ai
systems will be listening to this
podcast a hundred years from now
and it will probably there's some
nonzero probability they'll find your
words laughable
it's like i remember humans thought they
understood
something about the brain they're
totally clueless there's a sense about
neuroscience that we may be in the very
very early days of understanding uh the
brain but
i mean that's one perspective in your
perspective how far are we into
understanding
uh any aspect of
the brain so the the the dynamics of the
individual neuron communication
to the how when they in in a collective
sense how they're able to store
information transfer information
how the intelligence then emerges all
that kind of stuff where are we on that
timeline
yeah so you know timelines are very very
hard to predict
and you can of course be wrong uh and it
can be wrong in
on either side uh you know we know that
uh you know when we look back uh the
first flight
was in 1903. uh in 1900
there was a new york times article on
flying machines that do not fly
and and you know humans might not fly
for another 100 years
that was what that article uh stated and
uh so
but no they they flew three years after
that so it is you know it's very hard to
um so well and on that point one of the
wright brothers
uh i think two years before
uh said that uh like he said like some
number like 50 years
he he has become convinced that it's
it's uh it's impossible
even during their experimentation yeah
yeah yeah i mean that's a tribute to
when
that's like the entrepreneurial battle
of like depression of
going through just like thinking this is
impossible
but there yeah there's something even
the person that's
in it is not able to see uh estimate
correctly
exactly but i can i can tell from the
point of you know objectively what are
the things that we
know about the brain and how that can be
used to build
ai models which can then go back and
inform
how the brain works so my way of
understanding the brain would be to
basically say
look at the insights neuroscientists
have found
understand that from a computational
angle information processing angle build
models using that
and then building the that model which
which
functions which is a functional model
which is which is doing the task
that we want the model to do it is not
just trying to model a phenomena in the
brain it is it is trying to
do what the brain is trying to do on on
the whole
functional level and building that model
will help you
fill in the missing pieces that you know
biology just gives you the hints
and building the model you know fills in
the
rest of the the pieces of the puzzle and
then you can go
and connect that back to biology and say
okay now it makes sense that this part
of
the brain is uh doing this or
this layer in the cortical circuit is
doing this uh
and and and then continue this
iteratively
because now that will inform new
experiments in neuroscience
and of course you know building the
model and verifying that in the real
world
will you will also tell you more about
does the model actually work
uh and you can refine the model find
better ways of putting these
neuroscience insights together
so so i would say it is it is you know
it
so neuroscientists alone just from
experimentation
will not be able to build a model of the
of the brain uh or a functional model of
the brain
so we you know there there's uh lots of
efforts which are very impressive
efforts in
collecting more and more connectivity
data
from the brain yeah you know how how are
the micro circuits of the brain
connected with each other those are
beautiful by the way
those are beautiful uh and at the same
time
those those do not itself um by
themselves
convey the story of how does it work
yeah and
and somebody has to understand okay why
are they connected like that and
what what are those things doing uh and
and we do that by building models in ai
using hints from neuroscience
and and repeat the cycle
you